今日はドクターはじめね皆さんはスマートフォン使ってますでしょうか
お家にいる時間がフェリポン私が危惧しているのはスマホとかそういうものサーブ時間
が極端に増えてしまうことをこの動画はメディア皆さんも多分パソコンで見ている方も
いますけどもスマホで見てよね方がかなり多いと思うんですよ
そこで問題になってくるのが
[音楽]
スマホ is を負傷今や我々の生活には切っては切れないそうですね
今や我々の政界に今今や今
今や我々の生活において切っても切れない存在のスマートフォン生活の一部になって
仕事でも全部とが多いので手放すことはほぼ不可能と言われていますがかなりの人数の
方がスマホ依存症であると言われていますそもそもスマホ依存症とは何か
の僕もよく分かりません結構問題視されているみたいなんですよまあスマホ依存症とは
もう本当にスマホに頼り切っちゃってスマホが手元
にないとイライラして落ち着かないとか一日のほとんどの時間をスマホでなんか過ごし
ちゃうとかいう特徴があります
僕ですまだ僕の場合はまあん
筋トレとかしてるしスマホに依存しちゃうと結構いろんな問題が起きたり症状が出たり
こういうデメリットがあったり特に知らぬ間にスマホ依存症になってる方結構いると
思うんですよ今日はそんなスマホ依存症の肖像や特徴
そういうのをいま一度私と一緒に見返していきましょう心当たりのある方が気を付けた
方がいいです
ええええええ
[音楽]
その珍しく私なりにまとめさせていただきました結構調べたんで尿とマットを得たこと
が入ってると思いますまず少女
体の不調光る画面を見続けたりなこスマホを見ると背中が丸まるじゃないですかずっと
画面を触って創造し続けることによって舞方指などに不調が現れます視力な鋭角肩こり
や筋肉痛睡眠障害頭痛の痛みが現れると思います
スマホ指って言うんですか
なんかスマホ触ってると指が変形したりもするらしいんですよて馬鹿を見ると首が前に
出てねあの
こうなんかスタンド飾るまっすぐなクリーンな b やつストレートネックって言うん
ですけどもこれで背骨は個性の負担が結構重くなるらしいので結構問題になってる
みたいです僕です次の肖像
コミュニケーション能力の低下しゴーリーを
し母乳
熱湯会社コミュニケーションの命になりますと実生活での一つのしすることが極端に
少なくなることがありますこうなるとネットとか twitter とかでは目指して
いきがってよく書き込みとかするんですけども家族や友達との関係がどんどん小さく
なって現実世界じゃコミュニケーション能力の低下につながることがあります
ua
東なると現実でもどんどん言いたいことが言えなくなってネット内でちょっとでも
コーナーが気に食わないたら一歩ついて忘年入ろうとか悩んこいつはとか批判さいって
いうことが起きるガチャです人のことばっか言ってんじゃねー
自分の心配しを学力低下これも大きな問題ですね
凄惨なんですけどスマホ触っていないから使う常に気になっているため勉強会の cg
力がする
企画力低下に陥ります学校道でスマホ禁止の学校とかもあるんですけどもスマホ is
を所になるとそのスマホがないときにセライライラしちゃって余計集中できないとかに
もなってしまいませんで結構問題らしいですメインドクターはじめ携帯もず始めたのは
高校からですね大学受験中は勉強中は絶対スマホの電源を切るようにしてましたすぐ
返信しなきゃ秒これは怖いですよスマホ
依存症ってスマホゲームとか動画を見るだけじゃないんですよラインなどのメッセと
言った時にすぐ返信しなきゃいけない変身してなきゃ悪口書かれたりなんか嫌な思いさ
れるとか思っちゃうんですよねすぐ返さないけど今日はためのゲームの一つともされて
ますスマホはコミュニケーションツールでやっぱりスマホって払えない状況が生まれて
しまっているのも現実です
まあ俺は全然記録無視するけどねちなみに中学生のスマホ依存症は50%超と言われて
います女子校生80%以上がスマホ依存を自覚してるらしいですもう終わりまーの
やっぱ一番既読するらしいですねそのほりぞの原因は須藤浩の引き金学生さんのスマホ
糸のちょっとーくを引き起こす可能性となると懸念されていますスマホ依存になります
意味不足やうつ病愛鳥不良で学校休むケースが多くなる傾向があり先ほどもいった
コミュニケーション能力が低下ですね同級生とのかテーマはがんなんかとっくいいじゃ
なくなったら来るコーナーずあって学校に行きづらくなってしまう可能性がありますは
コードっ
どっ小学校
学校だよ
小黒に入るときます魔法を持っていく僕ですいや俺すごいぞそうだこれ誰も人と話をし
て言ってもスマホを使うことが多いこれもちょっとあの説明ですね僕はどうしても開催
に大変とかお仕事の話だってそういうことをしながら話するんだけどもやっぱり
と仲良してる時は向こうの顔とか見てねちゃんとか痩せた方がいい印象を持たれるかも
しれませんもう完全に人と
開発に話せなくなっているっていうのはもういい増床ですねで弾いてるぞ
えらくいれば他の作業をしていても通知が来ればスマホをチェックしてしまうこういう
人いますよねなんかスマホマッチョメンとか言ったらもうどんな作業とか支部ずの歌詞
でもにとりあえずサボチェックする人と言います
[拍手]
これを完全に依存の症状のひとつですね通知が放っておけないとはその方依存症の可能
性がありますスマホを手放さない
もう一日中スマホを手に持っているといると思いますもうスマホがないと不安になっ
ちゃうんでしょうね
瀬名波画面で見れて手で触れないところになって不安を感じてイライラしてしまうほど
の状態に陥ることもあります
[音楽]
ありがとう
やんないと1ないよ
ねえ
ねえっちょっ
ねぇこれも末期です僕ですはいという症状とか悪影響があるらしいですね
確かにスマホ触ってると寝れなくなったりしますよねスマホ首で増えストレートネック
になったりだとか
精神面が以来だとか不安6贋造霧氷所攻撃的になるなど上げられているんだよなんか血
がついたらそうなってたりすることが多いらしいんですよねか自分で話でめっちゃ一言
じゃない
やって感じがしてちょっと強くなりましたスマホに限らず何かに依存しちゃうと性格と
かそういうとこにも出ちゃうんで私も含め皆さんスマホの使いすぎには気をつけ
ましょう
でも
[音楽]
1日1回はあずみさんの動画を見てもいいんじゃないかな
チャンネル登録よろしくじゃない
あっハール haro ま